les années et rien pour ça les amis nous
sommes au gap sur une culture bilingue
c'est un endroit très atypique qui a
l'air très très coûteuse en y implantant
un instant parce que là je vais bouffer
geadah tout cela je mange je mange même
lui je le mange les amis je dois ma
bouffe trouver des chats ambiance
tamisée poser toi même tu sais la
particularité du village c'est qu'il ya
plein de street art et petite taille
vêtu comme ceci voilà le petit prince
revisité avec un privé ce pas toi tu
connais pour séduire de la meuf à 14 ans
les petites sandales tranquillou 1
ça c'est une faute de goût du coup on
est dans les hauteurs là tout ça ça a
été fait remarquer sur une autre colline
fabriqués ont dès qu'on parle de rejouer
cette déconstruction de cully et
regarder du coup on a une vue hyper
belle et très coloré de ces magnifiques
c'est incroyable on a envie de faire
croire de sortir le droit
[Musique]
comme vous avez pu le voir j'ai craqué
j'ai fait des plans mais le blème c'est
que ça vibrait énormément alors je sais
pas si c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
vent ou quoi mais comme vous avez pu
voir sur les plans on dirait que le sol
bouge et salut toi en fait dans ce
village il ya plein plein de chasse sur
les toits voilà j'en ai couvert s'assure
une espèce de pancartes donc très
content mais j'aurais vu que d'eau chez
nous pour éviter un char ont fait miaou
et syphon niang yang lâche en train de
faire le chien on connaît les points de
vue sur le région va vous dire que c'est
très trop gênant les pédales en fait
dans les montagnes comme ça il ya
beaucoup de relief c'est ça ressort bien
voilà c'était national geographic regret
c'est sûrement miro le meilleur winston
du monde ce revers brut a gagné le
championnat du monde de world check
satim la corée du sud est bon le mec
passe tellement qu'ils ont fait une
allée voilà et c'était une longue
introduction finalement pour une blague
un peu nul que les amis je suis jag
altima requête et c'est le plus grand
marché de poissons de corée du sud y en
a partout
[Musique]
les amis je me trouve devant un des
nombreux stands de poissons et il y a
les pénis fiche on dirait totalement des
pénis c'est incroyable je content que je
suis venu ici pas dans le but de manger
du bon poisson très très bon juste pour
voir des poissons forme de 8 et ce stand
est aussi un restaurant donc les moyens
qu'on m'a dit manger et chanter dans le
restaurant je suis content j'avais pas
vu mais c'est les acheteurs ou tu vois
un petit peu en mode traditionnel en
tailleur sous la table comme le manager
ci qu'ils assurent ta table basse ils
appellent à gris montréal il a pas dit
une blague il ya la langue du crabe du
poisson pénis or ce qui vous fait encore
et c'est que avant de tomber ce que tu a
commandé t'amène plein de punch à mme
ojeda sur l'a34 déjeuner au restaurant
ils ont à peine huit ou neuf ya tout ça
mon gars il s'agit pas commandé 1 c à
vous faire avec kita du kimchi pas du
chou taddei damas mais juste la télé
pepsi grâce à dzeko voici donc les
points c'est un pénis on dirait qu'il
arrive les couper près à l'étranger
c'était mon bureau que j'aurais fait les
choses écrit baguette coûte ça sent pas
mauvais
pas franchement j'avais écouté instant
j'ai ce passage pas battu on construit à
quelques coréens âgés qui va repasser en
regardant bizarrement je crois pas trop
fait pour lier à ici tu retires fait je
suis rentré et tu te mets en chaussettes
mais moi j'avais déjà fait plusieurs
paires de claques à terme et donc je
suis bien j'ai pris peur de plaquettes
le bohème c'est que ça ça appartient aux
employés du restaurant tuque rien qu'un
homme qui marche engin serait toutefois
ce fait pris sa petite femme faire des
blagues
elle a beau jeu de sylvain payer
l'addition aux médecins comme le poids
du vih est hors de ses claquettes
après franchement si je puis me
permettre je pense qu'il ya anguille
sous roche ok pour moi taper jouer
petites séquences cool
résumé du marché
[Musique]
que vous venez de le voir sur ces
dernières images on avait vraiment
décisif quoi en fait quoi quand tu
prends un tube presse il ya de l'outil
sans lui fins à redire
ils sont dix fois plus gros sans
déconner là c'est le poisson adultes
quoi bon comme en témoigne à cette porte
je suis à la fin du marché
c'était énorme et ce qui est étonnant
c'est qu'il ya plein de toit sont
partout et fruits de mer mais ce sont
pas du tout mauvais ça sent même mais
gabon ces housses ce qu'on va faire
maintenant c'est aller se détendre dans
une source chaude ça va être absolument
génial et reposant jade vous montrer ça
je vais mettre mon petit coeur de la
chanut comme ça on retire mes habits et
je vais m'introduire dans un bassin très
très chaude ça y est les amis je suis
pas dans quelques secondes je vais aller
dehors je vais cahier maras donc je
serai pas dans le jeu dans le beignet
qu'un bras hors de l'eau parce que j'ai
mon tatouage
je crois qu'il peut doit te baigner
pendant une deux ou trois semaines quand
tu vas me faire tatouer le froid nous
attend dehors donc les amis je viens de
sortir mais que sa mère faisait froid je
keisse cpo faut aller j'en sais rien
juste en train de mourir gratuitement à
la il ya un truc c'est quoi ça vous
allumez peut qu'être l'utilisé pas donc
c'est par là bordel je vais mourir avant
d'atteindre l'omec au [ __ ] c'est pas
là je fais demi-tour wijk bon énorme
effet je crois qu'en fait les trucs où
il ya de lau-balagnas pas de quoi du
coup je vais m'arrêter dans l'ascenseur
en fait le cinquième
c'est juste un beau père on sait par qui
la met
juste un espace open avec de la danse et
au quatrième étage c'est le spa des gens
là on va aller le blème c'est qu'il faut
se mettre en tête - pas donc j'ai pas du
tout filmé des moments d'exception plus
le mensonge pu filmer à dieu c'était une
expérience extraordinaire
j'ai moi je suis jamais très peu mettre
tout nu devant des gens ce qui est a
priori normal le chapeau à l'homo joue
pas je me fais me rhabiller en gros il
ya plein de douches des sources chaudes
à différentes températures sa fin fin de
ma vie que je vois autant de mecha poids
des assiettes ne serait ce pas je me
suis douché et il y avait trois coréens
au calme qui était comme ça sur leur
barda sur ce show dès qu'ils vont
observer
c'était très perturbant mais je me sens
bien ça m'a bien relax et ça a bien
marché en fait les coréens viennent ici
en fin de journée ça coûte 12 euros pour
6 heures il émet un petit espace pour
dormir tu veux te reposer faire une
petite sieste qui travaille énormément
et en reviennent ils se détendent il se
douche il se brosse les dents et il
retourne en soirée ou alors au boulot je
c'est parti là il ya plein de copains
qui me voient parler verlan casey
puisque c'est mon casier et il dévisage
j'appréhende est trop ce moment mais bon
je les ai faits et anecdotes aux
japonais la même chose mais c'était
source aussi en plein air ne s'étaient
pas en plein air c'est à dire un truc
fait pourquoi c'est un sport japonais a
vraiment plein de sources comme sa
chaude en plein air et a pas droit d'y
aller s'était tatoué parce qu'au japon
quand tu es tu as tout et on te
considère comme un yakuza le cas que les
yakuza qui font état de la mort je suis
dans le bain à 43 non je veux le faire
le kéké et ça m'a donné immédiatement
chaud donc je suis allé dans la piscine
à 22° exprès pour se refroidir sauf que
22 degrés après 43 talent raison que
c'est moins 30 degrés que j'ai mis les
pieds ça leur a fait du bien j'espère
que ce petit 3 4e jours encore il vous a
plu ces cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude et je vous dis à très
vite dans une prochaine aura bientôt
[Musique]